Hello, I'm Dr.
Sonia Rivera
-Martinez, Associate
Professor,
Department of
Family Medicine,
and our topic
for today is
History and
Physical Exam of the
Gastrointestinal
System Part 2.
Our session objectives
for today's lecture
includes appropriate
history taking,
special abdominal
examination techniques and
correlating these with
common etiologies.
Clinical features
for common abdominal
pain or contipation
etiology.
Correlating the
clinical presentation
with common etiologies
for constipation and
developing a differential
diagnosis and
treatment plan for a
patient with constipation.
We will have now a brief
discussion of the
history of pleasant
illness for
abdominal pain.
In the next few
slides, we're going
to be correlating
parts of the HPI with
different presentations
and what those
presentations might
mean. For example,
a patient complaining
of sudden,
like a light switching
on. You may think
of a perforated
ulcer, renal stone,
a ruptured
ectopic pregnancy,
ruptured aneurysm,
possible torsion of the
ovaries or intestines.
If it is less sudden,
it includes most
other causes.
Previous episodes might
include ulcer disease,
diverticulitis,
middle schmurz.
For palliation and
provocation, if
it is relieved by
antacids, you might
think about peptic
ulcer disease.
If it's relieved by
lying very still,
then maybe think
of peritonitis.
As far as the
quality of pain,
descriptions such
as acute waves of
sharp constricting
pain may be related to
kidney or biliary
colic, waves
of dull pain
with vomiting,
intestinal obstruction,
a sharp constant
pain worsened
by movement, may
be peritonitis,
a tearing pain,
think of dissecting
aneurysm, and
then a dull ache,
others such as
appendicitis,
diverticulitis,
or pyelonephritis,
many itises.
I skipped here
colicky pain that
became study. It can be
appendicitis,
mesenteric ischemia.
The place to where
the pain radiates
might also give you
a clue of what the
acute abdominal pain
may be. For example,
radiation to the right
scapula,
gallbladder pain,
left shoulder or ruptured
spleen or pancreatitis.
In the ***** or vagina,
it could even be
renal pain or back,
ruptured aortic aneurysm.
Let's see about
the severity. When
it's severe,
really severe, you
might think of a
perforated viscus,
a kidney stone,
pancreatitis, or
even peritonitis.
And pain out of
proportion to
physical findings.
This one is
common for
mesenteric ischemia.
In looking at the
timing of the acute
abdominal pain.
If it is gradual,
think of things such
as diverticulitis
or cholecystitis. If it's
paroxysmal,
perhaps intestinal
obstruction, renal
or biliary colic.
Persistent and
stable, fits
more likely pancreatitis.
As far as associated
symptoms that
occur with acute
abdominal pain. If you
have a patient that
states they have
vomiting that precedes
the occurrence
of pain and is
followed by diarrhea,
this may be related
to gastroenteritis.
On another one,
delayed vomiting with
absent bowel
movement, inflatis, it
could be related
to acute intestinal
obstruction. Note that
the delay increases
with a lower site
of obstruction.
Severe vomiting that
precedes intense
epigastric left chest
or shoulder pain.
Think of emetic
perforation of
the intra-abdominal
esophagus.
Now just a word of
caution, remember that
any of the symptoms
discussed in the HPI
slides, you need to
also be able to match
them up with any
physical exam findings.
So alone and themselves,
they point to
a suspicion to certain
etiologies without
the physical exam
findings, they
don't prove to be so.
So you need both of
them to come up with
the differential.
Now let us look
at abdominal
pain and anatomic
considerations.
Knowledge of the
location of the abdominal
pain can assist in
developing an appropriate
differential diagnosis
as it may target
the organs that may or
may not be involved.
As we will see in the
next few slides, we
will be using here the
four quadrants, right
upper quadrant, left
upper quadrant, right
lower quadrant, and
left lower quadrant.
Pain that's localized
to the right
upper quadrant can
be cholecystitis,
hepatitis, perforated
duodenal ulcer,
left upper
quadrant, gastritis,
or splenic disorders,
right lower quadrant,
appendicitis,
secal diverticulitis, and
the left lower quadrant,
sigmoid diverticulitis.
If patient
indicates that the pain
encompasses the entire
abdomen, think of
acute pancreatitis,
possibly early
appendicitis,
intestinal obstruction,
mesenteric ischemia.
For left or right
upper quadrant,
think of also
acute pancreatitis.
lower lobe pneumonia,
myocardial ischemia,
also ****** zoster. Make
sure you check the skin.
Right or left
lower quadrant.
You can have
abdominal abscess,
cystitis,
endometriosis,
abdominal wall hematomas,
fibromas, medial
schmerz, pelvic
inflammatory disease,
renal stones,
ruptured ectopic
pregnancy,
and others.
Let us review the
visceral pain patterns.
These pain
patterns follow
embryonic development.
So for example,
the appendix is a
midgut organ. Therefore,
you might start
off with visceral
pain pattern of
periumbilical pain.
That is very important
because people tend
to, initially with
appendicitis itself,
have periumbilical
pain that is vague and
then it ends up traveling
to the right side.
For the renal and
ureteral pain patterns,
you usually have
it flank that comes
starting from the back
and then travels to
the front all the way
to the groin region.
This is very common
for renal stones.
In referred pain
that is of extra
abdominal origin,
organs that are
outside of the
abdomen refer pain
into the abdomen.
For example,
a myocardial
infarction, the pain
can be felt as
if it was in the
stomach just
below the ribcage.
Lungs can also
have a similar
presentation, the
diaphragm and the
pelvic organs.
These are common.
Think of these as
possible places for
the etiology of the
acute abdominal pain.
We will now
proceed to cover
abdominal exam
special techniques.
Recall the order of
the abdominal exam.
You inspect, you
auscultate, percuss,
palpate, and then lastly
do the special test.
These are the
special tests
that we will be
reviewing today.
Assessment for
presence of ascites,
Deloitte sign, Murphy
sign, McBurnie's point,
rebound tenderness,
referred
Rupzig sign,
obturator sign,
and psoas sign.
To identify for the
possible presence of
ascites in a patient
that has bulging flanks,
you would want to
percuss for shifting
dullness. This is
you would start one
with the patient
supine and then you
would percuss starting
from the middle
of the abdomen in
which there should
be tympani and then
continue laterally
and you may hear
dullness. You go in a
semicircular
manner from either
left to right or
right to left.
The other manner in
which you might also find
if there is ascites
present, you have the
patient in a lateral
recumbent position and
you would then percuss
from the one aspect
okay to the dependent
side. In other words,
the part that the
patient is laying down on
that would be the dependent
side. So you would
start from the other
side, the non-dependent,
and percuss. At that
part you would hear
timpani and then
eventually you may hear
dullness that is in the
presence of ascites.
You can also attempt
to palpate for a
fluid wave. Here you
would need an assistant
to place their hands
in the middle as
shown in the picture
and then an examiner
places his or her
hands at the flank.
Then the examiner with
one hand applies a
sudden tap going towards
the middle with one
hand and monitors to
feel if they feel a
fluid wave on the other
side. And then you
can also repeat that
from the other aspects.
So you can do a tap
on the left and feel
on the right or do a
tap on the right and
then feel for the
fluid wave on the left.
The Lloyd sign,
also known as
costovertebral
angle tenderness,
you would tap between
T10 and T12 bilaterally.
You can either
strike the costal
vertebral angle with the
ulnar surface of your
fist or place the
ball of one hand on
the costal vertebral
angle and strike the
costal vertebral angle
with the fist ulnar
surface of the other
hand. Either way is
correct. You should
do this by laterally.
When Lloyd's sign or
costal vertebral angle
tenderness is positive,
meaning that when
you did the tap on
the patient with your
ulnar surface, the
patient complained of pain
directly in that area,
then you would need
to inquire about other
signs and symptoms.
What about their
voiding habits?
Additional personal
or family history of
genitourinary or renal
vascular disorders.
This table contains
medical causes along
with their clinical
manifestations for when
Lloyd's sign or
costal vertebral angle
tenderness is present.
In lephrolithiasis,
the patient would be
complaining of waves
or waxing and waning
flank pain that may
radiate. If there is
a perirenal abscess
then there would be
severe unilateral flank
pain along with
dysuria, fever, chills,
you might see erythema
of the skin and a
palpable abdominal mass
may even be present.
For acute
pyelonephritis, You would
have high fevers,
chill. There
would also be flank
pain and dysuria.
You would also see
blood in the urine.
Possibly the patient
might have nocturia,
urinary frequency,
anorexia,
and nausea and vomiting.
For renal artery
occlusion,
there would
be flank pain.
To elicit nerfy signs,
you could either hook
the left thumb or
fingers from the right
hand in the right
upper quadrant. Then
you ask the patient to
take deep breaths
during the palpation.
If
there is a sharp
increase in the
tenderness and the
patient suddenly
stops the
inspiratory effort
that constitutes
a positive test
and this would
be positive for
possible acute
cholecystitis.
Acute cholecystitis
is usually
related to
gallstone disease.
Customarily, there is
right upper quadrant
pain that is gradual
and steady. It may
radiate to the right
shoulder or back.
Patients will
typically have fever,
elevated white cell
count, nausea, vomiting,
and might have much
of an appetite.
There customarily
is also a history
of fatty food
ingestion and
Murphy's sign tends
to be positive.
Rebound may
also be present
due to peritoneal
inflammation.
Murphy's point is
located one-third from
the ASIS and two-thirds
from the umbilicus
in the right lower
quadrant. Pain at this
point is suggestive
of acute appendicitis.
Acute appendicitis
customarily presents with
point tenderness at
the McBurnie's point.
Right lower quadrant pain
that is gradual
and steady.
There is nausea,
vomiting, fever,
and anorexia.
You should assess four.
Rebound tenderness,
referred rebound
tenderness,
Robson signs,
psoas signs,
obturator signs,
and cutaneous
hyperesthesia where
touching lightly the
patient feels pain.
Peritoneal pain or
peritonitis. This occurs
when there is
inflammation of the
peritoneal cavity. There
are multiple causes,
but this is most serious
when it is present.
The patient might
die within a few
days, so it needs to
be recognized readily.
There are multiple
causes. As I
mentioned, the
most serious cause
is perforation
of the GI tract.
This perforation
may cause fluid to
shift into the
peritoneal cavity along
with also organisms from
the gastrointestinal
tract into the
peritoneal cavity.
The patient will
look very ill and
lies very still to
minimize discomfort.
Even bumping into
their bed might
cause them to be in
extreme discomfort.
So be very alert
to this one. It
has high morbidity
and mortality.
For rebound tenderness,
what you want
to do is palpate
the abdomen by
pressing deeply
with the pads of
the fingertips.
After a moment
of that pressure,
quickly release
the pressure.
Notice any signs of
pain either in the
face or that the patient
actually verbalizes
it. The test is
positive if there is
more pain with
releasing the pressure.
It is suggestive
of peritonitis.
Rebound tenderness
elicited in the right
lower quadrant is
suggestive of appendicitis.
Acute pancreatitis,
generally rapid at
onset. There is
severe mid-epigastric
or upper abdominal
pain commonly
associated with
alcoholism or gallstones.
There's many
other causes but
these are the
most common. There
is also nausea,
vomiting, fever.
Pain may be relieved
with bending forward.
The pain may radiate
to the back or
around both costal
margins to the back.
Referred rebound
tenderness. The
examiner would
palpate by pressing
deeply any one
of the quadrants
and then after
having the pressure
for a little bit,
releases it quickly.
Patient feels pain
in another quadrant
with the release of
pressure again with
the release of
pressure. This too is
suggestive of
peritonitis. So in the
arrows here you would
press on the left
and then pain is
elicited on rebound in
the right upper
quadrant. This is an
example of referred
rebound tenderness.
Acute diverticulitis
generally
occurs in
individuals who are
elderly but not
exclusively.
There is generally
either right lower
quadrant or left lower
quadrant pain that
can be present for
several days. This
usually occurs in the
left lower quadrant.
There is commonly
fever and
chills as part
of this syndrome.
Mildly distended abdomen
can also be present.
Bowel sounds are
customarily absent.
There is inflammation
and focal necrosis
if present may result
from bowel perforation
which make this a
lot more serious.
Recurrence is very
common so you should
really ask the patient
who you suspect has
diverticulitis whether
or not they've had a
episode previously and
you may feel a palpable
tendon mass in the
left lower quadrant or
the right lower
quadrant, depending on
where this diverticulitis
might be occurring.
Robsingh sign
is another sign
for suggestive
of appendicitis.
This one is different.
You palpate on the
left lower quadrant and
that produces pain in
the right lower quadrant.
It has nothing to
do, I repeat, nothing
to do with rebound
tenderness. It is simple
palpation on the left,
eliciting pain on the
right lower quadrant.
The obturator sign,
you have the patient
supine and then you
take their patient's
right lower extremity,
flex the patient's
right thigh at the
hip with the knee bent
and then you internally
rotate at the hip.
Bring the ankle outward.
Pain elicited in
the right lower quadrant
is suggestive of
peritoneal inflammation
and appendicitis.
The obturator
sign, if positive,
usually indicates a
pelvic appendix. It may
occur with right pelvic
abscesses as well.
The inflamed appendix
is in the pelvis
and in contact
with the upright
internus muscle,
hence producing pain
when with the obturator
sign maneuver.
The psoas sign
can be elicited
in two different ways.
One with the patient
supine, the examiner
places the hand
just above the
knee and asked the
patient to rise their
right thigh against
your resistance.
The second way is
to have the patient
turn onto their left
side and then the
examiner takes the
right lower extremity
and extends the
right leg at the hip.
With that maneuver
or the previous
maneuver, an increase
in abdominal pain
would be suggestive
of appendicitis.
With the psoas sign,
it may indicate, if
positive, that the
appendix is retrocecal
and orientation. note
that the iliopsoas
muscles is retroperitoneal
and the appendix
would lie over the
psoas. Pain is elicited
due to the friction
of the psoas muscle
against inflamed tissues
during the maneuver.
To complete the
physical exam here, you
would want to do a
****** examination.
Pain or interrectal
masses may be evaluated
during this
examination and you may
look for blood in the
stool. In females,
you should do also a
vaginal examination.
In males, a
testicular exam.
And in both females
and males, make sure
you evaluate for the
presence of hernias.
All of these can be
related to the acute
abdominal pain or
can be a cause of it.
Key points to
remember when
performing these
special tests.
Always observe
the patient from
the right side
of the patient.
Always explain to the
patient what
you are doing.
Observe the patient
for signs of pain.
Don't rely only on
verbal cues that
they're telling you
that there is pain.
More importantly,
the special tests
are used to
confirm a diagnosis
you are considering
from your history
and other abdominal
examination.
We will now discuss
evaluation of
constipation, which is
a very common complaint.
This is from our
previous lecture, but as
a reminder for the
discussion of today,
definitions of
constipation.
For physicians,
it's fewer than three
bowel movements per week.
For patients,
it may mean hard
stools, feeling
of incomplete evacuation,
having to strain
excessively, a sense
that there is a
blockage in the
**** ****** region
during defecation,
and also the need
to perform manual
maneuvers to be
able to ********.
There are several
clinical subgroups related
to constipation. We
have primary colorectal
dysfunction which
includes normal transit
constipation in
which there there is
normal **** ******
function and the transit of
the stool throughout
the colon is normal.
Then you have slow
transit constipation
which also has normal
**** ****** function
but there is
prolonged delay in the
stool transit
through the colon.
Next, you have
defecatory disorders.
These are characterized
by impaired ******
evacuation from
inadequate ******
propulsive forces,
meaning that there is
difficulty pushing the
feces out, or there
is increased resistance
to evacuation.
Of this defecatory
disorder, there
is anismus,
which occurs
because there is
a high ****
resting pressure,
and dyssynergia,
which is incomplete
relaxation or there
is paradoxical
contraction of
the pelvic floor
and the external
**** sphincters.
You also may find
a combination of
overlap disorders
that would be the
slow transit constipation
with defecatory
disorders would
be an example.
These may possibly
be associated
with irritable
bowel syndrome.
In approaching the
patient with constipation,
there should be a
clear understanding
of the patient's
complaint of
constipation. You need
to obtain the specifics.
What is it that
they are referring
to when they talk
about constipation?
You want to determine
if there is the presence
of any secondary
causes. also to consider
if there is metabolic
and structural
causes and then do an
evaluation accordingly.
If appropriate you
might do a trial
of having them take
over-the-counter
fiber plus or
minus laxative and
even consider
biofeedback therapy.
If there is an
adequate response to a
therapeutic trial, then
consider doing additional
testing such as ****
rector manometry,
recto balloon expulsion,
and others. Do
not be concerned
about these. This
is more for your
general knowledge
of these testing.
Regarding the history,
you want to ask the
patient what is the
symptom that is
most distressing to
them and give them
examples such as is
it because it's
infrequent, you have
to strain, the stools
are hard, or is
Is there symptoms
unrelated to bowel
habits such as
bloating, pain, malaise?
Need for peritoneal
or vaginal pressure to
allow stools to be
passed or direct digital
evacuation is required.
You want to make sure
you ask these kinds
of questions to your
patients and then note
whether or not there may
be evacuatory disorders
that do not respond
well to laxatives.
So that's the
need why you would
need to have
this information.
How often does a
patient feel the need
to have a bowel
movement and whether
he or she feels a
sense of incomplete
evacuations. Are
they using laxatives?
If yes, how often
and what dosage?
Suppositories,
enemas? How often
are the bowels
moved? And what
is the consistency
of the stools?
On physical, you
should include an
abdominal exam
and a ****** exam.
Also depending,
you may need to
also include a
vaginal exam in
females to check
for ****** seals.
Check for signs of
anemia, weight loss,
abdominal masses, whether
or not their liver
is in charge, and if
there is a palpable
colon. inspect the
perineal for hemorrhoids,
which may interfere
with evacuation,
skin tags, ******
prolapse, hence this last
one was the ones that
I was talking about,
also to look in the
vagina of a female.
Ask patient to strain
and check if there's
any leakage and descent
of the perineum.
Test for an **** wink and
pelvic floor dysfunction.
Do a digital ******
exam. Make sure
that you determine
whether or not the
sphincter tone is
normal and assess the
****** walls to
feel for any masses.
Evaluate for
presence of a ******
seal. That's what I
mentioned earlier.
The place where the
patient complains
of a new onset of
constipation might
also clue you in
into certain causes.
For example, in
the hospitalized
patients, drugs and
supplements such
as opioids, calcium
channel blockers,
nonsteroidals, iron
supplements, antihistamines,
all of these can
cause constipation.
In the hospital,
the patient would
experience reduced
physical activity.
That too is a cause
for constipation,
particularly if
bedridden for
a length of time of
more than two weeks.
After surgery, it
takes a while to
recover from effects
of the anesthesia
which might also
cause the constipation
or slow the recovery
of the intestinal
movement that proposes
the feces out.
Dietary change may
not have enough
fiber in the diet of
the hospital food.
Dehydration that's
a big one. A lot
of people don't
drink sufficient
water to be able to
have normal bowel
movements, electrolyte
disturbances,
***** impaction,
intestinal obstruction,
all of those are
common causes
of constipation
that is a new
complaint in a
hospitalized patient.
Here are some clinical
features and clinical
correlation to what
might be the etiologies.
For example, in colon
cancer, if it is new
onset of constipation
in an older patient
associated with blood
in the stool, or
if they don't see
blood in the stool
with iron deficiency
anemia, positive *****
cult test, weight
loss of more than
10 pounds. Note that
patients, Females
who have no longer
menstruate and older
males, they should
not be losing iron.
So that is a key
there as there might
be the possibility
of colon cancer.
Irritable bowel
symptoms where there
would be abdominal
bloating and cramping.
Pelvic floor dysfunction.
You would have
prolonged straining.
The patient would
feel the need to do
digital evacuation.
Lack of pelvic
lift when you
do a digital ****** exam.
sacral nerve
pathology. Hence, you
would check for
the **** wink. If
it's not present,
then possibly there
is pathology of
the sacral nerves.
***** impaction.
When you do the
digital ****** exam and
there is leakage of
stool, this occurs
a lot of the elderly,
particularly those
who have not been
really well hydrated.
and **** fissure,
the presence of, when
there is pain on
digital ****** exam.
The differential
diagnoses for
constipation includes
many disorders,
abdominal hernias,
psychological, endocrine
disorders, which
lead to neuropathy,
particularly this is
seen with diabetes.
infectious
disease, sepsis,
neoplasm, meaning
the presence
of malignancy
in the colon,
neurodegenerative
disorders,
rheumatological
disorders, and of
course gastrointestinal
disorders.
It is very important
for you to know when to
order an endoscopic
evaluation for a patient
complaining of
constipation. This would
be in general for patients
older than 50 years
old with no history
of colorectal cancer,
before doing any surgery
for constipation,
change in the stool
caliber, a heme
positive stools meaning
that there is
presence of blood,
iron deficiency
anemia for females who
are postmenopausal
and men in general,
whether or not there
is the presence of
obstructive symptoms,
****** bleeding,
****** prolapse,
weight loss, and that
there is a recent
onset of constipation.
Note that these
indications may
also be part of
those for a screening
colonoscopy but
not all of them.
We will now look
into a case of
constipation. Here
Here is a 62 year old
female coming to your
office complaining
of constipation
that started about
nine months ago and
has been worsening
over the past three
to four months.
She currently
reports one to
two bowel
movements per week.
She states that she needs
to strain to ********.
She produces hard stool
and feels she does
not completely evacuate.
The patient has
tried increasing her
fiber and fluid intake,
eating prunes,
drinking prune
juice, but nothing
has been helpful.
She states she is
unable to produce
stools without
using laxatives. She
denies nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea,
blood in stools,
abdominal pain, abdominal
bloating, changes to
the form of her stool,
fever, chills, fatigue,
or weight changes.
For her past medical
history, she has high
blood pressure,
hypothyroidism, and
hyperlipidemia. For past
surgical history, an
appendectomy and
cholecystectomy. No allergies.
For medications,
she takes enalopril,
levothyroxine, atorvastatin,
and vitamin D3.
As social history,
she denies tobacco,
alcohol, or recreational
drug use. She drinks
one to two cups of
coffee a day, is married
and ******** active
with her husband.
The patient is a
pediatrician. She
eats usually a healthy
diet. On family
history, her mother
and father are
alive and well.
She has no sibling.
She does have
two daughters
who are also
alive and well.
For health care
maintenance,
she is up to date.
On review of systems,
all of the items
asked of her
were negative.
On physical exam,
the patient's
vital sign was normal.
General chest, heart,
lungs, abdomen,
extremities, skin,
musculoskeletal, neuro, gait,
****** examinations
were all normal. On
osteopathic structural
exam we found L1 flexed,
rotated, and side
bent right. We did a
Guayaquil test which
was negative times 1.
Let us now summarize
this case. We
have a 62-year-old
female presenting
with a complaint
of constipation for
the past nine months
and worsening over
the past three to
four months. She
has 1 to 2 bowel
movements per week,
strains to ********
hard stools, and
has a feeling of
incomplete evacuation.
She increased
fiber and fluid egg
take and it was
not healthful.
She must use laxative
to produce stools.
She has a history
of hypertension,
hypothyroidism,
hyperlipidemia, had
an appendectomy and
a cholecystectomy.
Physical exam, including
****** exam, was
all within normal
limits except for the
osteopathic structural
exam finding of L1 flex
rotated side bent right
and then we did a lab.
Guayak stool was
negative times one.
Let's look into
now possible
causes for this
patient's symptoms.
Would it be
Chagas disease,
hypothyroidism,
functional
defecation disorder,
irritable bowel syndrome,
or colon cancer.
Chagas disease is
caused by Tripa Sonoma
Cruzi. The vector is
triamptamine bugs.
There are major
manifestations for Chagas
which include myopathy
and gastrointestinal
disease. It has several
forms and phases,
usually found in the
southern cone of South
America and Central
America and Mexico.
The symptoms,
usually it is slowly
progressive,
constipation,
there is abdominal
bloating, less
often you might
find colically
abdominal pain.
The patient may be
unable to pass
stools for weeks.
There would be a history
of recurrent volvulus,
which is a twisting
of the colon,
and anorexia may develop.
Consider all
of these in the
case then's presentation.
In hypothyroidism. Now
know that our patient
does have a history
of hypothyroidism.
In hypothyroidism,
what you have
is a thyroid gland
that does not
produce sufficient
thyroid hormone.
Most common cause by
inflammation
of the gland.
There are other
causes including
congenital radiation
treatment, surgical
and radioactive
iodine treatment.
Risk factors include
being a female,
being over the age
of 50, and symptoms
would include
constipation, depression,
fatigue,
feeling slowed down,
joint or muscle pain,
thin, brittle hair
or fingernails, and
unintentional weight
gain. Again, look
at how our patient
presented it and
see if it coincides
with any of this.
For functional
defecation disorder and
like disorders, we
use Rome for criteria.
All of these
criteria require that
the fulfillment
of the specific
criteria for the
disordered be present
for at least
three months with
the symptom onset
of at least six
months prior to
the diagnosis.
So the patients
will satisfy the
criteria for
functional constipation
with the following.
During repeated
attempts to ********,
the patient must
have at least two
of the following.
Evidence of impaired
evacuation based
on balloon expulsion
test or imaging.
Inappropriate
contraction of
the pelvic
floor muscles or
less than 20
percent relaxation
of the resting
sphincter on manometry
or inadequate
propulsive forces
assessed by
manometry or imaging.
Then you might
have this divided
into two different types.
Dysinergic
defecation, which is
inappropriate contraction
of the pelvic floor
or less than 20%
relaxation of the
sphincter pressure.
And then you also
have inadequate
defecatory propulsion,
which is inadequate
propulsive forces
with or without
inappropriate contraction
of the **** sphincter.
Correlate this with the
patient's presentation.
Another possible
syndrome,
irritable bowel
syndrome, room
for criteria
again is used
and to meet the
criteria there would be
recurrent abdominal
pain at least one
day per week in the
last three months
and that is associated
with two or more
of the following
related to defecation
onset associated
with change in the
frequency of stool
onset associated with a
change in the form
appearance of stool.
Criteria again
must be fulfilled
for at least three
months with the
symptom on fit at
least nine months.
Then you have if there
is a constipation type.
Patient reports that
their abnormal bowel
movements are
usually constipation.
Have a hard time
passing stool, need to
strain, feel cramps,
often do not release
any stools or only
a small amount.
Intensity of the
symptoms vary on and off.
Again look at
what the patient's
symptoms are and
this criteria.
Colon cancer usually
all types start as non
-cancerous polyp then
progress to cancer.
Risk are patients
older than 60,
African-American or
European descent,
diet high in red
or processed meats,
family or personal
history of cancer,
irritable bowel disease,
symptoms, abdominal pain,
diarrhea, diarrhea,
constipation, or other
bowel changes, narrow
stools, weight loss,
blood and stools,
and anemia without
other GI symptoms.
Okay, so now let's look
at the working diagnosis.
Chagos disease, unlikely.
Even though
the patient has
a history of
hypothyroidism,
it is unlikely
as she is not
presenting with
anything new, has
had this disorder
for a while.
Functional defecation
disorder is most
likely, but we would
have to do other studies.
Irritable bowel
syndrome is a maybe,
and so is colon
cancer a maybe.
So now that we have
summarized everything,
let's do from the S
and the O, subjective
and objective, we're
going to move to the
assessment and plan.
Here we have differential
diagnosis and
assessment of functional
defecation disorder.
We said irritable
bowel syndrome and
possible colon cancer.
The patient does have
hypothyroidism,
hypertension,
and hyperlipidemia,
and we found the
somatic dysfunction of
the lumbar spine. So
our plan is going
to check her thyroid
with a TSH and a free
T4. Do a CBC to find
out if she has anemia
of iron deficiency
and a complete
metabolic panel. This
would be for her other
disorders. We will
do GUIAC stools
times three to double
check the one that
we did in the office.
Order a gastrointestinal
specialist consultation.
This would be
for her to have
consideration of
a colonoscopy.
Continue her
current medications.
Do a behavioral
psychologist consult
that would help
if she does indeed
have functional
defecation disorder.
And also to conduct
biofeedback therapy
of the pelvic floor
and retraining,
education on diet,
low salt, low
lipids due to her
disorder. We would
do OMT at a future
visit or at that
visit and follow up
after visit to GI.
These are the references
that were used
for the preparation of
this lecture. They're
all listed under
the respective slide
number for you to
be able to look for
additional information
if you choose to do so.
This concludes
this presentation.
Thank you very much
for listening. Please
complete the survey
lecture feedback
form. The link is
below. Again, thank you.